Ваговий контроль фур в Україні став завданням державної ваги на початку цього літа,
коли президент Зеленський доручив ловити порушників-далекобійників
і назвав їх "засранцями", які, за його словами, розбивають новозбудовані дороги.
Тепер президент вирішив підсилити роботу "Укртрансбезпеки"
представниками Нацполіції та навіть СБУ, і пообіцяв встановити на дорогах України
50-80 комплексів автоматичного вагового контролю.
А як вагові та інші перевірки працюють у Німеччині?
За що ще штрафують далекобійників на німецьких дорогах?
Перенавантаження фур у Німеччині суворо контролюється.
Штрафи становлять від 35 євро до 425 євро залежно від того, наскільки перевищено ліміт,
причому штрафують двічі: і водія, і фірму. Кілька "зайвих" кіло - не проблема.
Санкції починаються від 5 відсотків надмірної ваги.
Як підкреслюють водії з досвідом їзди в Україні, у Німеччині контролери
значно суворіші і непідкупніші. Перенавантажену фуру
однозначно зупиняють і подальший проїзд не дозволяють.
Під контрольне зважування можна потрапити не лише на кордонах, а й на автобанах.
Інспектори з мобільним обладнанням заганяють туди вантажівки
з підозрою на перенавантаження. Зрідка можна зустріти стаціонарні автоматичні ваги,
які вимірюють транспорт, що рухається на швидкості 30 км за годину.
Наприклад, у Дуйсбургу їх встановили, аби не пропускати особливо важкі фури
на аварійний міст через Рейн. Абсолютно неприпустимою вважається вага понад 40 тонн.
Порушників зупиняють і скеровують на спеціальну парковку,
де ще раз ретельно зважують і оформлюють штраф.
Схопити штраф можна також за неправильне закріплення вантажів.
Щоп'ять років водій зобов'язаний проходити спеціальний тренінг із закріплення,
який триває 5 днів. Якщо ж під час контролю виявляються надірвані ремені
або інші вади у кріпленні, то карають грошима потрійно: водія, його фірму
та фірму-експедитора, яка доручала вантаж, адже погано закріплений вантаж
може становити смертельну небезпеку для інших учасників руху.
Хто їздив німецькими автобанами, мабуть, бачив колони фур,
які їдуть одна за одною по автобану. На рік німецькими дорогами курсують
від 800 тисяч до 1 мільйона 200 тисяч вантажівок. На деяких відрізках автобанів
їм можна їхати лише у правій смузі і заборонено обгін.
При цьому водій вантажівки зобов'язаний тримати дистанцію до найближчого автомобіля,
аби уникнути наїзду в разі різкого гальмування.
Спійманим на недотриманні дистанції загрожує штраф від 80 євро і більше.
Контролюють у Німеччині не лише патрульні поліцейські, а й інспектори BAG -
відомства вантажних перевезень. Цих контролерів
описують як доволі суворих, з якими не посперечаєшся.
Перевірки вантажного транспорту - основна їхня діяльність.
Перевіряють, зокрема, і сплату MAUT - дорожнього збору за проїзд автобаном,
а також накладні, вагу, лічильник відпочинку.
Цей лічильник - улюблена тема далекобійників.
За кермом водієві можна бути максимум 90 годин упродовж 2 тижнів.
На добу дозволено кермувати не більше 9 годин.
За ці години мусить бути щонайменше одна перерва - не менше 45 хвилин і не пізніше,
ніж через 4 з половиною години їзди.
Дані лічильників можуть зчитуватися інспекторами навіть на відстані.
Коли ловлять на "недосипі", штрафують. Недотримання відпочинку на 1 годину
загрожує штрафом від 30 євро для водія і ще від 90 євро для його фірми.
Такі приписи призводять до того, що німецькі парковки на автобанах переповнені фурами.
Далекобійники скаржаться, що нерідко доводиться мало не годинами
шукати вільне місце для зупинки. Але контролерам це байдуже.
Якщо водій не зміг вчасно відпочити, буде штраф.
Або ж мусить паркуватися з порушенням і тоді отримає штраф
за неправильне паркування: від 10 до 80 євро.
Однак усі ці штрафи - ніщо у порівнянні із суворістю покарань за водіння напідпитку.
До пів проміле алкоголю у крові далекобійнику штраф не загрожує,
якщо він не везе небезпечний вантаж. Але спійманий з пів проміле і більше
сплатить 500 євро штрафу та позбудеться водійських прав на один місяць,
якщо це перший раз. Відкупитися, як у Східній Європі, тут неможливо.
А спійманий за кермом з 1,1 проміле або більше вважатиметься профнепридатним
і назавжди може втратити водійські права. Окремий виняток становлять ті,
хто перевозить небезпечний вантаж, вони зобов'язані бути "прозорі як скельце" - 0 проміле.
Нерідко напідпитку на німецьких автобанів ловлять водіїв з України, Польщі
або інших східноєвропейських країн. Щоправда, поліція у Німеччині
не може відібрати водійське посвідчення у порушників-іноземців,
і це їх, так би мовити, "рятує". Але лише доти, доки не сталося ДТП.
Тоді наслідки можуть бути драматичними. В окремих країнах ЄС,
зокрема Польщі або Нідерландах, почали встановлювати протиалкогольні замки на фурах.
Пристрій вимірює дихання водія, і машина заводиться лише тоді, якщо водій тверезий.